Welcome to week two in the robotic vision
project. The objective for this week is to
capture an image of our Robot Vision worksheet
and get it into MATLAB.
The choice is really up to you whether or
not you want to use a local camera, such as
a compact camera or a mobile phone camera
or you could use a web camera if you like.
I've already written a function in MATLAB
that allows me to do this, so let's go into
MATLAB now and take a look at what this looks
like in the MATLAB workspace.
Okay so I've taken a photo of the Robotic
Vision worksheet using my mobile phone camera,
I've saved it onto this computer and I named
the image RV.JPEG.
So how we actually get this image into the
MATLAB work space? So currently it's just
a file, so how do we actually access the image?
Well the robotics toolbox has a function called
"iread" so we're going to use that function
to load in the image.
So we'll create a variable called img, call
our iread function and we can just simply
supply the file name that we want to read
in. Again as you can see on the right, we've
created a new variable called img, these are the pixel dimensions of the image and it has three channels.
Any time you read in an image, it's always
a good idea to actually visualize it, just
to make sure that nothing funny has happened
and the robotic vision toolbox has another
function called idisp, which allows you to
actually visualize the image and see what's
come into the MATLAB work space.
So as you can see here, this is out Robotic
Vision worksheet. Now when you guys take a
photo of your worksheet, there is just three
things that you should keep in mind; the first
thing is that make sure that all of the shapes
are actually visible, so don’t, you know,
only photograph half of the worksheet and
make sure it's not too far away. Just make
sure that the worksheet comprises the majority
of the image. That way it's easy for you to
identify the 2D objects later on in the project.
The next thing is that when you take the photo,
just make sure that you're not, you take it
with a steady hand. So that will reduce any
blurring because we're trying to find and
identify the 2D objects, any blurring will
make that process a lot more difficult. And
finally because the 2D objects are colorized,
we're relying on colour segmentation, so there
must be an appropriate amount of illumination
when you take your photo, so just make sure
that you can actually distinguish between
the different colours, so you have enough
level of light, such that is possible.
So if you follow those three tips and you
get something that looks something like this,
then you're all good to go onto the next part of the project.